[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
so yes thank you shopping for inviting
me to speak about this haven't talked
about this in years and so it's always
exciting to talk about something so
we've seen the power of zero knowledge
in the digital world right yeah you
could use zero knowledge to prove that
you have the key to decrypt an encrypted
file you could get a certificate from
from from say Experian that's just a
signature on some form that has your
details about you and your identity but
just has your credit score and then
prove and zero knowledge to someone else
that you have a credit score without
revealing to them the other details of
your identity and perhaps the most
famous application right now that is
widely used you can prove that you have
some confidential transaction that is
valid on a ledger based payment system
like Z cash or Manero using a zero
knowledge proof that does not reveal any
of the details of the payment that you
made perhaps even your identity but
let's talk about a different kind of
setting which is much more embedded in
the physical world right so far the
three examples I gave were purely
digital statements right you have some
digital statement that you're proving
like there's an encrypted file and
you're proving that you have the key to
decrypt it but here let's say that I'm a
suspect in some crime investigation and
the police or the investigators have
collected a DNA sample from the crime
scene how could I possibly give a zero
knowledge proof that my DNA does not
match the DNA taken from the crime scene
and how could I do that without
revealing anything about my identity
so a strawman proposal the suspect or
someone on behalf of the suspect through
the suspect trusts could sample the
suspects DNA measure it turn it into a
digital form and give a standard digital
zero knowledge proof that the measure
profile does not match okay but the
problem with that is that there's
nothing preventing the suspect from
cheating on the measurement it's in the
translation process from a very physical
statement that my DNA has some property
to translating that into some digital
form that is not secure right the
investigators have no way of knowing
that that the sample was was measured
properly so on the other hand you could
say well let's let the detectives
measure the suspects DNA but the problem
there is that there would be no privacy
the detective might save a little bit or
learn the actual raw profile of the
suspect so we can state the problem as
saying that there's no soundness because
the prover is not trusted to measure the
physical sample itself and there's no
zero knowledge on the other hand if we
did it the other way because the
verifier would not be trusted to measure
the physical sample and not learn
anything from it so we can see that this
physical zero knowledge problem does
present something that the world of
digital zero knowledge doesn't quite
solve and so some something new is
required to address this now this isn't
the first example of physical
cryptography or cryptography that
involves something inherently physical
that is not that is somehow slightly
outside of the the problem realm that we
consider when just considering
computational problems or
logical problems so one one example
would be distance bounding protocols
where you can where you're trying to
prove that you're close to a certain
location and one application of that
would be to try to prevent someone from
setting up some relay stations to say
you're you're far from your car and you
have an RFID tag that allows you to
unlock your car then someone could set
up some relay station in order to do
some some men in the middle forwarding
and and pretend that they're actually
have your AR FD RFID tag right next to
the car so that's also an inherently
physical problem and very long well a
long time ago for me at least people
designed distance bounding protocols for
that and still today work on that there
was early educational examples of zero
knowledge with physical protocols
protocols that that involved decks of
cards or cutting out pieces of paper or
covering our parts of pseudo kupaza 'ls
mostly for educational purposes there
was a informal example of a zero
knowledge protocol for nuclear warhead
verification trying to prove that two
nuclear warheads are have-have have
similar radiographs and the application
of that was to nuclear disarmament where
you would prove that you're actually
destroying nuclear weapons without
revealing to the authorities the details
of how those nuclear weapons were
constructed and then the paper that I
did wrote with monie and and and Daniel
physical zero knowledge proof of
physical properties kind of took this a
bit further and tried to formalize what
is physical zero knowledge and gave a
few more examples of physical zero
knowledge protocols one of which I'll
talk today which is applied exactly to
this DNA forensics problem
so the cop-out solution would be okay
let's just say that there's some trusted
party who can measure the DNA and
produce a digital digital form of the
DNA sample and then from there we can
use digital techniques but we don't want
to do that we would like to do something
better than that so consider the
following very simple physical
interactive protocol and I don't know if
any of you ever played the Coke and
Pepsi blind test game I did in my I
think freshman psychology course in
college where we were I was asked to
demonstrate if I could tell the
difference between Coke and Pepsi and
the the verifier so to say for the
instructor of the course would take the
Coke and Pepsi behind his back and
shuffle the cups and give me one and I
would demonstrate that I could
distinguish whether I was given Coke or
Pepsi and you might be also familiar
with the graph not isomorphism
interactive protocol which you may have
learned in your first course on
complexity theory and that similarly is
based on the same principle where prove
or who knows that two graphs are not
isomorphic is able to demonstrate that
it can distinguish between whether it's
given one a random permutation of one of
the graphs or a random permutation of
the other graph so we'll apply the same
basic idea here the suspect or a
defender on behalf of the suspect who
has access to a lab will demonstrate
distinguishing ability between the
sample taken from the suspect and a
sample taken from the crime scene now
it's important to note that the
investigators here are not allowed to
measure the sample taken from the
suspect there is some physical
assumption here that they are being
observed while they're doing this so
they can handle it and place it behind
their back but they cannot measure it
so the police would randomly select a
challenge one of either S or C give it
to the defender and the defender would
measure it and declare the identity of
the challenge sample the defender should
fail with probability 1/2 if the two are
identical now this is making a lot of
assumptions first of all so first of all
this is really zero knowledge what if
the police sneak in and say a third
sample and would learn something about
the relationship between a third DNA
sample that was not even involved in
this problem to begin with and the crime
scene sample or the suspect and is it
actually sound perhaps there's other
differences between the two samples that
allows the defender to distinguish
between them that you know that have
nothing to do with the fact that they're
taken from the same individual so let's
sweep those aside for a moment let's
look first at or at least let's let's
sweep aside the second part let's let's
assume that the defender does not really
have a way of distinguishing between the
two samples other in any other way than
if they were taken indeed from two
different individuals and I'll explain a
little bit more later about how DNA
profiling actually works and why that
might be a reasonable assumption to make
but let's first focus on the the first
issue how do we how do we ensure that
the police aren't sneaking in some
different samples so one thing we could
do is use tamper evidence seals tamper
evidence seal is I like the one you
might find on a water bottle and you can
tell that the water bottle hasn't been
opened and let's say that we have these
tamper evidence seals that are
manufactured also with random serial
patterns so the defender can uniquely
identify the seal and for the duration
of the protocol the police are not there
given the seal during the protocol and
they're not able to forge another copy
of the seal and produce another sample
that has exact
the same seal so how would we apply this
in the in the physical interaction well
the defender would place seals on the
two test tubes marked SN C and the
police would cover up the seal markings
so that there are two test tubes are no
longer distinguishable randomly select
one of the challenge the defender would
remove the seal without removing its
cover measure it and declare the
identity of the challenge but now
instead of declaring the challenge
publicly you would send a cryptographic
commitment to the challenge and for
those of you who don't necessarily know
what a cryptographic committment and it
is it is basically it has two properties
it is it is binding there will be some
later phase where the defender will be
able to reveal what this message it
committed was and there's a unique
message that it can reveal and it's
hiding until then so there cannot be
distinguished from random before them so
now the police will remove the cover so
the defender can check for the marks and
ensure that this is indeed a sample that
is not from outside of the the two
samples it expects to be there
and only then will after everything is
checked to be okay will a D commit to
answer that it gave and you could repeat
this k times to amplify the soundness
error of 1/2 to 2 to the minus K so
modulo the very strong physical
assumptions that the protocol seems to
work but the resulting protocol is very
physically complex and there are many
physical assumptions about the setup and
you know interactive physical protocol
involved first of all we need to have
these unforgeable tamper-evident seals
the parties need to closely observe each
other throughout the whole interaction
to ensure that the correct sequence of
operations were made when the police
take the samples behind their back the
defender needs
please don't somehow sneak out you know
part of the suspect sample or or
actually measuring while they're doing
that and involves it is it's it's highly
you physically interactive so again is
there something we could do better so
from here I will introduce notion of a
public observation protocol which has a
direct physical analogy to public coin
proofs in the world of digital
interactive proofs so a public coin
proofs in particles are more generally
interactive proof systems in computer
science are one in which the verifier
does nothing more than generate random
challenges when each time it receives a
message from the prover so the proofer
gives a message to the verifier and the
verifier just gives a a gives a random
challenge in response and so they're
called public coin proofs because the
verifier does not really have any secret
randomness right now the verifiers
messages are in a public observation
protocol you know should be all digital
okay so there's nothing that's
physically concealed you can think of it
as if the verifier is sitting behind a
glass screen and observing the prover as
it's doing things so you may need some
kind of physical observation there or
perhaps the the prover is even just on a
video monitor
but the verifiers only interaction is to
send random digital challenges so this
would reduce tremendously the physical
assumptions on the interaction
so before designing a public point
version of the previous protocol so do
you see why the previous protocol was
was not a public observation protocol
because the defender sorry the
investigators the police were allowed to
take the samples behind their back and
choose one secretly and give it to the
defender and it was hidden which one
they chose so they had to physically
hide some of some of their what they
were doing from the from the front
approver so let me tell you a little bit
more about how DNA profiling works which
will be more needed now in order to
describe how the public coin version of
the protocol would work I have some
animations in here I think that are
residual from like 2012 or 2013 that I
haven't completely detected yet since I
copied some of my slides over so yeah so
DNA profiling works by comparing
different gene regions that have these
so-called str sequences which are short
tandem repeat sequences and there's
about 13 different regions that are used
in at least profiles that are measured
in the US and what are short tandem
repeat sequences they're short DNA
sequences such as for example a ga ta
which will repeat many times over in a
certain region and the in different
people the exact number of repetitions
of this sequence at that given location
will defer so a profile is measured by
looking by measuring the length or the
number of repetitions of these short
sequences at 13 different locations and
that produces basically a vector of 13
different values which can often
identify a person
now also note that everybody has two
different versions right
tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu different versions of
this location on the two different
chromosomes so there will be an allele a
which is just a variant a in a variant B
and so they may have two different
values in that vector location rather
than one that's a detail so the way that
they're actually measured is by using
these things called DNA primers in this
process called the called PCR which
basically cuts out the DNA region with
some flanking region as well so it cuts
out a length of what we'll call n plus X
where n is the actual length of the
sequence and X is something that is
specific to the primers that were used
so you cut out this thing of length n
plus X X is known if the primers that
were used for this reaction are known
otherwise it may it may not be known and
this is amplified and then there's a way
of measuring this by running it through
some capillary tube and basically seeing
how how fast it goes through which will
allow you to distinguish its length okay
so the smaller fragments pass larger
pastures and the larger ones and there's
a laser that detects the fragments as
they pass by and that's what allows you
to measure or estimate the length of the
fragment and it's very precise so how
are we going to design this public coin
DNA in a quality protocol
so let's now just look at the DNA
profile as a vector okay say just a 13
values and this vector each value in
this vector corresponds to like the
length of their of the individuals STR
sequence at that low side but we'll just
think of them now as vectors and so the
problem becomes proving that the vector
taken from the suspect is not equal to
the vector taken from the crime scene
when now the the intuition behind how
we're going to design this public coin
DNA inequality proof is based on the
idea that when the two vectors are
different okay then if you look at the
combined set of these two together right
now I have I have two profiles and I
define the set of the number of distinct
profiles that I have so if I have two
distinct profiles I have a set of size
two and if I have only one distinct
profile even though I have two samples I
have a set of size one that's how I'm
defining this set Z okay and I could
amplify that difference by looking at
many copies of the you can always take
many different samples from the same
individual right so I could look at you
know this higher dimensional vector
which has many many copies of taken from
both the suspect and the crime scene and
the number of possible combinations that
I could make of the two of them is now
much larger if I have two different
vectors to take from whereas if I only
have one vector to take from then
there's only there's only there's only
one combination that I can form they're
all the same right so I have a set of
either size 1 which is just the appended
vectors together of one type or I have a
set of size 2 to the
we're in each I can either choose from
the crime-scene sample or from from the
suspect sample to form a different
element of Z to the K and to this the
way that and this is actually how the
generic transform from private coin to
public coin protocols works in the
individual world is to apply this thing
called a set lower bound protocol which
was designed by goldwasser and sip cert
in 86 and so a quick review of how the
set lower bound protocol works if you
have some set quality which is a subset
of binary strings of length n let's say
and approver wants to prove that T is
much much greater than some value T to
the N to the M then the proof system
uses a universe to aid a pairwise
independent universal hash function
family and the verifier selects randomly
a hash function samples the hash
function from the family the prover then
gets this as the first message and tries
to find some elements Y in the set T
that hashes to zero the intuition is
that if the set is much larger than
there is a higher probability that the
prover will be able to find such an
element whereas if the set is smaller
then there is a lower probability and
the verifier will accept if the if h of
y is equal to 0 and may need some you
can think of this the subset T of 0 n to
the N as some kind of language and so it
may also need some extra proof or
certificate which it wouldn't be able to
verify on its own but the prover knows
that Y is actually in the set T so this
this has been shown to be a complete and
sound protocol and there's also a
zero-knowledge version in this protocol
where there's a slight
there's like difference in in how and
how Y and H are sampled Y is sampled
first randomly from T and then H is
sampled from the set of hash functions
which map that value to zero so let's
just try to take this tool and see how
we can apply it in our very physical
setting okay so the problem is that I've
just what I've described you so far is a
purely logical version of this protocol
I said we have these two vectors and
then we can form the Cartesian you know
prod product and we can look at Z to the
K either you have a very large set of
possible combinations of the crime scene
vector and the suspect vector or you
just have one and so there's if I hide
that in digital form then there would be
a way of the applying the set lower
bound protocol to show that I either
that I have a large set and not a small
set but how do I map this into the
physical protocol itself how do we apply
this goldwasser sips or you know set
lower bound protocol to a physical set
so the way this is going to work is
we'll have the police again they'll be
viewing the entire interaction from
behind the glass string so they're
observing that the that the verifier is
following that the prover is is
following the protocol correctly okay
and that is important at least that the
physical actions that the approver is
taking are according that are correct
according to how the protocol is
supposed to work so first there's a
preparation phase where the where the
where the prover takes forms sake a
pairs of test tubes okay where in each
pair the left one is taken from the
suspect and the right one is taken from
the crime scene sample and then we'll
the the idea of how this this this
protocol will work and I'm I'm going to
not yet talk about how the how exactly
to make this zero knowledge but first
just how to make this sound okay and
then we'll look at how to make it zero
knowledge so the next step is for the
police who are observing this to sample
just random challenges and give it to
the and get and and and and give it to
the approver okay and then there and and
and and then there is there would be a
this is describing how let me take a
step back so if if we were to write so
if we were to do this basically the the
the the the prover is trying to show to
the police that if it were playing this
interactive game were to where were to
be given a random sample taken either
from master C okay then it would have
would it would end up with a much larger
set
a much smaller set so it's kind of
pretending in its head
that the prover is you know showing like
what what what what was simulating what
the provers challenges would be okay and
so the only thing that the prover needs
to do is say sample a random a random
challenge to tell it which one which
which one to take from each of these
it's not that the the prover does not
know the prover does know which one
comes from s and which comes from C so
it's not exactly the same as the
previous interactive protocol but the
prover is just showing that it has a
much larger set so what we end up with
is the the prover is basically sampling
a random combination is sampling the
verifiers is is directing the prover to
sample a random combination of these
test tubes taken from either s or C so
we end up with is this vector Z 1
through ZK where each one is is directed
by the by the police which one the
prover takes and so then the defender
can just measure that okay and then the
applied the set the set lower bound
protocol where the where the police
basically give it a give it a hash
function and there's a the N and the and
the and the defender is going to try to
find a hash function which Maps this
vector to zero so the only thing that we
didn't quite solve is that the vector
that is now revealed okay is still a
combination of the actual pure samples
taken from SRC and we wanted to make
this a zero knowledge thing so what
we're going to do is we're going to
first transform this in a way that
preserves the same set size okay but
that is when when when when when one
element is revealed from each pair from
when one test tube is revealed from each
pair it does not reveal anything about
the suspect sample
and so the way that we'll do that is by
leveraging that random primers that we
could that we could use which adds that
extra length to the to the scr sequence
which is dependent upon the primer that
is used so during the PCR reaction if
the ret if the primers are chosen
randomly but applied identically to both
the crime-scene sample and the suspect
sample then what we end up with a
fragment and plus random are from look
from the from the crime-scene sample and
and also n prime plus R from the suspect
sample and so if you're only revealing
one from each pair then you would not be
able to distinguish this from random now
let's assume that the capillary
electrophoresis device can out display
the output mod n so let's ignore the
slight bias there and so this physical
transformation is that from each pair of
test tubes we choose a random primer in
in in each in each reaction and since we
only reveal one of the two test tubes to
the police from each pair of test tubes
and that the police do not know the
random primer that is used they just
know that the same random primer was
used in the reaction on both test tubes
then they cannot they cannot distinguish
this value that they see from random but
again if s and C are not the same then
we will end up with many many possible
you know
vectors whereas if they are exactly the
same then there is one predictable
vector that is determined from the
primers and so that is the nutshell of
how it works now I could ask leave with
one kind of open question which is is
there a way to make this non interactive
so the one of the reasons why the coin
protocols are quite useful in the in the
digital world is that you can apply this
Fiats aamir transform to make them non
interactive
and the way that's done is by applying
basically a hash function to each of the
provers message which then determines
the challenges that the verifier would
send and so I leave with the question a
visitor like a physical kind of hash
function that could probe the pair of
test tubes to get a measurement a unique
measurement to that object which would
behave like a random Oracle and there's
a connection to this other line of work
called physically on cloneable functions
which and examples include looking at
optical sad scattering or gate and wire
lays in micro electronic circuits but
they're usually defined specific to a
object they're not that there's some
hash function that could be applied to
any object which would which would
behave in a similar way to a random
Oracle in a collision resistant hash
function the digital world applied to
messages but anyways in conclusion a
physical zero knowledge presents a new
challenge that goes beyond digital zero
knowledge and its physical zero
knowledge forensics is possible but
might still be impractical the protocol
I described was quite still quite
physically complex but there's still
always more questions to ask in
investigate here
[Applause]
yes yes yes well a test of inequality
[Music]
could you generalize this this protocol
- right - to proving that you're not
that you do not have a DNA profile that
belongs to set right well so you could
always so I think that the question is
there is more about efficiency right
because you could prove that you're not
in the set by proving that you're not
equal to any element of the set and just
run this protocol for each one
individually but why do you give me two
criminal
okay well but if you I mean it depends
on your on your assumptions about the
physical interaction right but we could
the investigator has the the set of so
it is it is it are which are we do I
have as approver the set and I'm trying
to prove that nothing in my set is
distinct from the crime scene sample or
is there a set of crime scene samples
and I'm a suspect and I'm trying to
prove that I'm not in the set so you
could go you could go through and one by
one run this supposedly zero knowledge
protocol with each element of the set
and prove that you're not equal to any
element in the set but there wouldn't be
efficient so it'd be more interesting to
see if there is a way of lowering the
complexity of the protocol where there's
a hope that would be interesting right
yeah I haven't thought about that but
there might be just a generalization of
proving that you have larger set versus
smaller set but
a rather silly question
yeah closeness essentially what do you
say is like suspect versus from crime if
you're a close tentacley close then you
could have you know not seekers one but
they're pretty close due to the power k
it could be closer to one so they could
be like this between the two sorry I
didn't understand
so if activity if you have charity
closeness yeah some bridges would be
close it won't be like a secrecy that's
it but you could still have okay you can
I prove that I'm connect the body
produces their false positive right
right right
so there can be false positives in DNA
profiles yeah and this protocol wouldn't
distinguish against that because it's
just proving that you have two different
distinct DNA profiles you may not
actually be this so there absolutely it
would be possible to have false positive
but that is more of a guess a flaw in
the in the profiling mechanism and I
think they would just look at more of
those I made a larger profile
[Applause]